Watch the shocking confessions,
admissions by the Orthodox Jews and the
secular Jews and the Zionists because
Stephen Anderson went around interviewed
Orthodox Jews.
Okay,
watch here. Here's the link.
Watch here. Let me go to full screen.
Chi, he's like Ar, another pig of Satan.
May they repent. Watch how many
officials,
senators, how many of our presidents,
pastors
have gone to the whailing wall with a
yamaka.
It's not only redon
watch
that Christians must support Israel.
They also demand that the US government
support Israel militarily and
financially.
>> Now, this is over 10 years old. Even
back then, Israel was trying to entice
America to bomb Iran. And John Hegy
says, "We need to make a preemptive
strike against Iran." And this document
is over 10 years old and they're doing
it right now. This has always been in
the works.
And because evangelical Christians make
up a large part of the voting populace,
politicians dutifully make See that?
Your politicians. Look how many
is that? Sarah Palin,
Mitt Romney, the late I can't sell her
who he is. Here you go. Hillary Clinton.
All of them. What? Let me not say all of
them. How many of them are in the
Epstein files? a high-ranking spy who
had ties with MSAD, whose girlfriend's
father is part of Mossad, started it,
and who had connections with all these
world powers and governments and could
set up meetings for Israel's prime
minister.
See that?
>> Make the trip to is
>> see
is that the seventh day Adventist that
was interviewed by George Enko?
I forget his name. Barack Obama. Huh?
And this guy is that conservative. I
forget his name. Mitt Romney, Sarah
Palin, Hillary Clinton.
Say that
his daughter became Jewish. Betray
Jesus.
>> Israel to pray to the
>> Oh, we got more H.
See that? And he's
is he kissing it?
The Jewish God at the Whailing Wall.
>> Wow. Perry supports Netanyahu's Congress
speech.
These are your senators, United States
of Israel, and you think America is not
bought. It's not actually United States
of Israel. You serious? Are you waking
up to the delusion?
It's the United States of Israel, buddy.
There's a a lot of uh socially
conservative evangelical Republican
voters who care a lot about this issue.
And if they can see Ted Cruz coming out
on Fox News and saying, you know, I am
100% behind Israel. When they see that
happening, a lot of conservative voters
are going to say, "Hey, this Cruz guy is
better than I thought."
>> In fact, they just had the Christians
United for Israel event, which is
>> Christians United for Israel. I got to
stop at key point so I don't get
flagged. Okay.
Christians United for Israel. All right,
let's see. Hold on. Get ready. Oh, by
the way, did you hear about the Muslim
terrorist that
several people injured about 14? Was it
in Texas? Turns out he's a Muslim and he
had a shirt with Allah on it. So, it's a
Muslim terrorist. It's a terrorist
attack. Do you hear about that? Now, how
many in the media is going to tell you
it's a Muslim terrorist? His shirt said
property of Allah.
Yep. mass shooter in Texas.
>> Yep. Now, watch here.
>> Which is an organization of evangelical
Christians that are that are that are
very very pro-Israel. This is a image. I
think we have this of Rand Paul praying
with them. Um this is
>> so praying for Senator Ran Paul at the
capital for what? Praying to do what?
>> The Christian Zionist to help Israel,
United States of Israel.
>> There there he is. He's he's praying
with the Kufi folks. Let me say this.
Those who hate Israel hate America. And
those who hate Jews hate Christians.
Who said we hate Jews?
But why do you equate loving Jews with
standing for Israel and her policies
which are anti-Christian?
>> So opposition to Israel is opposition to
God.
>> See that? And I don't care what they
believe and where they're at on the
spiritual timeline because it's not my
problem.
>> See that Jim Staley who went to jail for
tax fraud. By the way, Jim Staley,
it's not my problem. Opposition Israel's
opposition to God.
It's not my problem.
This is the nasty demonic cancer fruit
of Christian
that wants to defend. I hope he shows up
so I can end his career.
No, you know. All right, let me see if I
skip to the one hour. Well, hold on. We
can play it from here. Yeah, let's just
play it from here. I have his back.
And it doesn't matter what he does or
where he's at.
>> See,
>> but as long as he calls upon the name of
of Yahweh, the God of Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob, that's my brother. That's my
brother. So he doesn't believe in Jesus.
He thinks Jesus is a false messiah.
His mother was
who got pregnant by a Roman soldier
Panti Panda.
But it doesn't matter as long as he
calls on Yahweh.
>> There's going to be, I think, a a turn
towards a more biblical Christianity, a
more a more
>> guess who's saying it, an Orthodox Jew.
This is an Orthodox Jew.
So the more biblical you become, the
more in love with Israel and the Jews
you'll be.
Okay?
>> Or Jewish Christianity. And the the
lines between us that was like, "Oh,
those are Christians. Those are Jews."
are going to be like, "Oh, those are
sort of like our those are our
brothers."
>> Israel is grateful for the support of
America's people. and of America's
presidents from Harry Truman to Barack
Obama.
>> In fact, I am proud to say that no
>> Harry Truman and Barack Obama in fact I
am proud to say in fact I'm proud to say
this is going to get into Jesus in a
minute. You guys enjoying this so far.
So I've been doing a lot of writing
about Jesus and Tomud as well as Israel
not being the seed Jesus is because
guess what's going to happen? Christian
Zionism and the frenzy.
attack Iran, incite Russia and China to
World War II, a nuclear holocaust, cuz
that's what we got to do to bring Jay.
Go see this week how many of these
Christian Zionists will be in a ecstatic
frenzy bordering on demonization,
salivating at this war because they
think it's fulfilling Ezekiel 37-39.
Watch, look, and count. See if I'm
wrong. No US administration has done
more in support of Israel security than
ours. None. Don't let anybody else tell
you otherwise.
[cheering] It is a fact.
>> We recognize Israel's right to defend
itself and that it is right for America
to stand with you.
>> Therefore, it is time for America.
>> Now listen, John Haggy, this documentary
is over 10 years ago. It is time for
America to do what? Listen to John HGY
>> to embrace the words of Senator Joseph
Lieberman and consider a military
preemptive strike against Iran to
prevent a nuclear holocaust in Israel
and that was over 10 years ago.
That was over 10 years ago. This fat
slob sorry excuse of a man let alone a
Christian pastor John Hegy. We should
agree with John Lieberman. So over 10
years ago do a preemptive strike on
Iran.
Prophecy fulfilled. You're seeing it
right now.
You understand? Israel has been pushing
for this attack on Iran for years at
America's expense at the expense of
American soldiers lives. In fact, I
think a report came out. Iran bombed
back and some American soldiers were
notice American soldiers.
Where's the IDF?
Your sons and daughters.
Did you hear it from the cow's mouth?
What did a cow say?
Therefore, it is time for America
>> to embrace the words of Senator Joseph
Lieberman and consider a military
preemptive strike against Iran to
prevent a nuclear holocaust in Israel
and a nuclear [cheering] attack in
America.
>> Notice how it is. You got to do it cuz
Israel is going to protect you from the
Iranians from nuking you.
But now how guess how bad it gets.
Christian Zionists, I have two clips to
play from this. I want you to explain
this to me. Now Christians, listen to
this. Can you, a Christian who loves
Jesus, go and become a citizen of
Israel? If I'm a Christian Zionist and I
love Israel and I want to live there as
a Christian, can I to be a citizen, not
just live there? Can I be a citizen of
Israel as a Christian? Listen guys,
listen. So, where are you going to get
livid?
>> In 2 Chronicles 19, a godly king by the
name of Jehoshaphat was going to help
Israel militarily. Here's what God told
him in verse two. And Jiu, the son of
Hanani the seer, went out to meet him
and said to the king Jehoshaphat,
"Shouldest thou help the ungodly and
love them that hate the Lord? Therefore
is wrath upon thee from before the
Lord." So, we're told today that if we
support the nation of Israel, we're
going to be blessed by God because of
Genesis 12. When in reality, the Bible
teaches that if we help an ungodly and
wicked nation like Israel, we'll have
God's wrath upon us.
>> Absolutely. And now, my post, go read my
post. I wrote it in honor of this uh
documentary to give you biblical verses
show he's right. And I'll do a session
on who the seed is. It's not Israel,
it's Jesus. But now, watch. Can I go and
become a citizen of Israel as a
Christian who has pumped millions of
dollars into Israel because I love
Israel and they know that I love Israel
and I want to be a citizen Israel.
Listen listen,
where are you? David, where's your boy?
You're Benoi.
Why should we as bibleelving Christians
support the nation of Israel when the
nation of Israel won't even allow a
Christian to immigrate to their country?
If you want to immigrate to Israel, you
have to renounce the name of Jesus
Christ.
>> So for someone to become an Orthodox Jew
or have the right of return, they have
to renounce Christianity, for example.
>> They do. By the way, this uh he's a he
was over 10 years ago. I don't know if
he still is. I think he's the director
of a Jewish center in Arizona because
he's in Arizona. They do. Did you hear
it one more time?
>> The name of Jesus Christ.
>> So for someone to become an Orthodox Jew
or have the right of return, they have
to renounce Christianity. For example,
>> they do.
>> You cannot be a Jew and a Christian.
>> It's one or the other. So with regard to
the modern state of Israel, it requires
the renunciation of one's former
religious.
>> It requires ain't that the truth of
Syrian prince. This guy is so solid
biblically on this issue. It's shocking,
man. of all people. I would rather have
10,000 Stephen Andersons who will go out
and say the Bible condemns sodomy and
sodomites and homosexuality and it's an
abomination and transgenderism. It's all
evil from the pit of hell and you're
going to burn in hell and you can't
support Israel. It's evil. than
Christian Zionists
or even from my own camp who are too
ashamed to tell the tell it like it is
what the Bible says about these issues.